لقد تحدثت إلى الأشخاص الذين قالوا إن
اللقاحات
ساعدت على
تهدئة أعراضهم ، خاصةً شركة Pfizer ، التي قال ضيفي التالي إنها عانت منها في الربيع الماضي ، جودي دود ، بدأت إحدى المدرسات تعاني من
أعراض مرض كوفيد -19 ،
ضيق في التنفس ، صداع ، الإرهاق
بعد تلقي الجرعة الثانية
من لقاح covid19 تقول إن
أعراضها اختفت ، جودي تنضم إلينا
الآن
مع الدكتور ويليام لي ، المدير الطبي
لمؤسسة تكوين الأوعية
، كان يدرس
عربات النقل لمسافات طويلة أه مثل جودي وأنا الآن
جودي أنت تعرف أنك مع العائلة أه هنا
أنا  لست هنا للحكم عليك ،
وآمل أن تكون على صواب ، ولكن فقط
اعطنا ،
دعنا نحافظ على هذا الضوء ومحكمًا ،
لماذا تعتقد أنه
بعد اللقاح الثاني من شركة Pfizer ،
هل لديك شركة فايزر ، لقد
رأيت حقًا فرقًا ملحوظًا
أخبر الجمهور
حسنًا ، بعد لقاحي الأول ، كنت
بائسةً
، وصداعًا بسبب الحمى المنخفضة الدرجة ، والصداع نوعًا ما
يشبه نوعًا من الأعراض الطويلة المدى
، ثم بعد لقاحي الثاني
في اليوم التالي ، أصبت بحمى شديدة
ثم تابعت ذلك ببضعة أيام من
التعب والصداع
الشديد ثم استيقظت أه كان
صباح أحد أيام الأحد ، كان اليوم الرابع ، اليوم الرابع ،
استيقظت وكان مثل تلك
الإعلانات التجارية للقهوة أنت  انظر إلى المكان
الذي تشرق فيه الشمس للتو ، لقد
شعرت بتغير كبير في الموقف ، استيقظت على
استعداد للذهاب ،
ولدي طاقة الآن ،
لقد اختفى ضيق التنفس
آه ، ذهب الصداع بشكل أساسي ، لقد ذهب
التعب ،
أعني أنه يمكنني القيام بأشياء مثل
شخص عادي تعرفه يمكنني طهي العشاء
لأولادي.
اللقاح الذي كان علامة
فارقة بالنسبة لك وليس بلورات نكهة فولجرز في
القهوة ، أنا
متأكد من أنه كان الأفضل.
هذا
امممم
ما هو احتمال وجود
علاقة
وسببية  بالنسبة لمسافة طويلة
مثل جودي ، فأنت تعلم أن شركات النقل لمسافات طويلة كانت
واحدة من هذه
التقلبات والألغاز في Covet-19 ،
إنه مرض أربكنا في الواقع
تقريبًا في كل منعطف
، والسائقون لمسافات طويلة هو واحد آخر
منهم وكما  تم طرح اللقاحات
وحوالي 40 بالمائة من الأشخاص الذين
تلقوا لقاحًا وفقًا لمسح حديث
للمرضى أم الناس الذين يعانون من
أهوال طويلة ري
أه أه أفادوا أن رحلاتهم الطويلة
أه أه تقلصت أعراضنا
وبعض الناس قد
تعافوا بالفعل من  الأعراض لذا من
المستبعد جدًا أن تكون تأثيرًا وهميًا ،
نعم الآن نحن بحاجة إلى الانتباه
لفهم السبب لأنني كنت
سأضرب جودي بتأثير الدواء الوهمي ،
فلماذا ليس
جيدًا في المقام الأول لا يوجد سبب للاعتقاد
بأنك  معرفة تأثير الدواء الوهمي عادةً ما يكون هناك
توقع لحدوث شيء ما ،
وتوقع اللقاحات ألا
يصاب هؤلاء الأشخاص
بالعدوى بالفعل مثل جودي ، وبالتالي هناك وما زال
يعاني و  هل تعلم أن
الشيء الوحيد الذي يعرفه كريس جيدًا عن شاحنات النقل الطويلة
هو أنك حقًا حساس
بشكل رائع
لما يشعر به جسمك ، لذلك عندما لا يكون
شخص ما وجودي الشخص الوحيد
الذي أمتلكه من
المرضى الذين كنت آخذهم  اهتم بمن
سيرسل لي رسالة نصية من اللون الأزرق
بعد أن يحصلوا على لقاحهم ويقول الدكتور
لي إنني أشعر بتحسن كبير ولا أستطيع
تصديق ذلك ولذا لا يمكننا أن
نفهم أننا لا نملك التفسير حتى الآن
ولكننا  بحاجة إلى الانتباه
يبدو أن شيئًا ما يحدث